we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
really important voicemail I received
that I want to address take a listen to
this
hey David I really love the show I've
been watching for years now and I
haven't heard you talk about what your
perspective is on young people joining
the military yet and for me as a 17 year
old I'm being influenced by many
different perspectives and I'm planning
on joining the Marines after my senior
year in high school
right and I would like to have your
voice on what the risks are for me or
your basic opinion on the whole matter
and thank you for listening okay so
listen
number one the risks to joining the
Marines are being killed in armed
conflict right that's sort of the the
obvious and number one risk when you're
joining the military of course most
people who join the military aren't
killed an armed conflict that's the
reality I am NOT someone who says no one
should join the military because the
u.s. is going to have a military and the
reason we don't have a draft and people
who really aren't suited for the
military don't have to go because we
have a volunteer military that although
it does have some recruiting issues and
it sort of always been an issue at least
for a couple decades except for maybe
the short period after 9/11 we have a
volunteer military and thus we don't
have a draft so I'm not just like a no
one should ever join the military there
are situations where it's probably a
logical or sane decision to join the
military now the things I would tell you
are a few number one you could end up
even if you don't end up dead or maimed
you could end up having to fight a
conflict that you don't agree with
politically so if that's a concern if
that would be damaging to your essence
as a human being that's something that
you should think about harden hard and
fast or seriously but there's sort of a
bigger thing with joining the military a
lot I know a lot of people who have been
in the military who joined right after
high school during high school years
after high school not for everybody but
very often they're joining the military
to fill a need or scratch an itch that
other and
Devers could help them with so for
example if you want to join the military
to see the world and you don't want to
pay to travel around consider joining
the Peace Corps or doing Teach for
America there are other ways to see the
world not on your own dime and if that's
what's attracting you to the military
then consider that if you're looking to
work for your country if you want to do
something for your country there are all
sorts of other ways that you can do that
from the local to the federal level
everything from Foreign Service
diplomacy if you're saying I'm not
suited for that law enforcement at the
local or state level other sorts of
volunteer organization feel like you're
doing something for your country if you
want to be around guns well I would
explore why it is that you're so
desperate to be around guns that you're
willing to join the military to do it
given that there are so many other ways
to be around guns I could go on with
other examples but for many people I
find that the reason they're joining the
military is actually something that
could be met in other ways and it's
really important to think about what are
you actually trying to achieve if it's a
sense of infrastructure and discipline
there's other ways to achieve that as
well and many jobs and working in law
enforcement or working within you know
even working within like an airline if
you want to become a pilot the
discipline and infrastructure thing
exists in other ways so I would just
think hard and fast about what's
actually attracting you to it and
whether this is really the best path
towards that attractor or if there are
others we've got a great bonus show
today I'm out of time but trust me it's
a really good one it includes george
costanza actor Jason Alexander becoming
the new Colonel Sanders and much more
become a member at WWN pakman.com and
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show